all right Ashton yes Ashton uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally I'm from La Mirada California
tell me about your family you had both
your parents uh yes I fortunately have
both my parents
um they are uh currently divorced
um
so uh growing up like my first memory of
my mom and dad is of them fighting in a
motel room
and of course
like shortly after that my dad he kind
of disappeared without any you know
goodbye or anything like that
so after he disappeared my mom was left
to raise all four of us me my sisters
and it was very difficult for her
because she was a female addicted to
drugs and I do believe that she was very
heartbroken over my dad leaving us and
she actually started getting high with
my oldest sister
and
um that was just a very bad environment
because I saw a lot of inappropriate
things and was around a lot of bad drugs
and stuff like that that I shouldn't
have been around yeah
of your four sisters which ones are have
taken a path similar to your mouth uh my
oldest one and me the other two are okay
yes
what kind of things were going on in
your childhood that
you you'd consider
inappropriate or whatever
um well let's just say that you know I
was a child and because I wasn't being
supervised I once entered a room or I
saw actually two siblings
um
and having intercourse with each other
and for me that was like very
traumatizing because they introduced me
as brother and sister they'd introduced
themselves to me as brother and sisters
so when I read later on saw this it was
just so very traumatizing and
inappropriate and I didn't know what to
think of it
and then I would also be around like
drugs and especially cigarettes
cigarettes were always in my reach and I
remember me and my sister sneaking a
cigarette and I was probably like three
or four years old and we tried smoking
it and just things like that and also
just people like a lot of grown men that
would try to do inappropriate things
with me and my sisters
was your mom there to try to protect you
or she was
most of the time my mom was busy like
she just wasn't there I'm assuming that
she was off getting high with someone
somewhere
how far are you in school excuse me how
far did you go in school oh as well as
school I went as far as to
um
I'd say like my sophomore year in high
school but while I was in high school
the high school said that I was getting
too bad of grades so I didn't qualify to
stay in that school so they sent me to
like continue continuation school where
there were a lot of kids like me there
who probably had a bad childhood just
like me and So eventually I dropped out
of that and just got my GED
what have you done since since got out
of school
well since I've gone out of school I
haven't really stayed in touch with my
friends from school and
um I basically just was always at home
alone with so much time on my hands
really kind of just bored with nothing
to do and my mom but at this point she
kind of had gone to a rehab and cleaned
up her life so I was living with her
and she was working every day so like I
said I had so much time on my hands at
home alone she would try to encourage me
to get a job but I just didn't have it
in me like The Willpower to want to do
that so I eventually I met somebody on
my 18th birthday who is now my boyfriend
and because of his age difference from
me my mom said that if I was going to
stay with him that I couldn't be at home
with her and my dad said the same so me
and him became homeless and during being
homeless is when I really started to
struggle with my addiction with drugs
how many years older than you is he my
boyfriend he's at least 30 years older
than me
you
are living where now
right now I actually don't have nowhere
to live I was living with my boyfriend
in his car but it got towed so I have
nowhere to live now
so you're just finding a place to crash
every night yes basically
and drugs became a part of your life at
what age
drugs became a part of my life
um I would say like the 12 or 13 was
when I first started smoking weed
and then by the time I turned 16 I was
already doing math like the first time I
did it I did it with a needle because my
friend did it for me and because it was
such an awesome High I got addicted to
it at the age of 16.
what are you using today today I'm doing
fentanyl yeah
how do you support yourself now
I support myself
um
by panhandling I just ask people for
money and if that doesn't work I steal
from the store to try to steal something
valuable so I could trade it for drugs
a sex work ever been a thing for you
excuse me is sex doing
um I've had a lot of people that try to
get me into trading sex for drugs which
I try to turn that down when people like
say that they want to try to be my pimp
but unfortunately sometimes I'm so
desperate there is no other way to get
drugs besides to trade sex for it so
I've had to do that a few times
your your mom is still
addicted to this day
um she actually she tells people that
she's sober and she's not addicted
but for some reason I'm the only person
that she's actually open to and so she
tells me like you know that she'll do a
line of cocaine here and there and she
tells me about it so she struggles with
that still
um
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear is doing too much
Fentanyl and overdosing and dying have
you did before
I've OD'd before and thankfully the
individual who helped me out had Narcan
so I was brought back from my overdose
and I just remembered that but wherever
I was when I was either dead or
overdosing was a very lonely miserable
dark place I think I consider that as
hell
how old are you now now I'm 24. 34.
do you have kids I have no kids no kids
what emotions do you go through living
this life
emotions that go through are just
very weary
um confused
um desperate
um like anxious
um
scared traumatized
and scarred
have you tried to quit
fortunately I tried to quit one time
but that only lasted for about seven
days
what's it like trying to quit fennel
trying to quit fentanyl is I think one
of the hardest things I've ever been
through
um it's just
like every second I'm thinking about
the drug and doing it and it's really
hard for me to try to put my focus on
something else so that I'm not thinking
about it and not only that but I cannot
sleep and I feel like the only way I
could sleep is with it and you know I
just feel like depressed also like I get
a lot of pains in my body like body
aches
and I feel like my body physically needs
it you know and uh on top of that I get
a lot of cold sweats like I'll wake up
like if I do doze off and get any sleep
I'll wake up sweating but then at the
same time I'm cold
is this your lowest point right now
I always say so yes
you still talk with your sisters
um no
you had to live your life all over again
what would you have done differently
I probably would have done differently
you were kind of you grew up in a
situation an environment that was
surrounded by drugs so you can't really
at that age choose what you're going to
do
yeah
um
I would have probably
done things differently by
asking like
letting and probably bringing it to the
attention of somebody who could have
helped me right your circumstances are
really rough excuse me your
circumstances were really rough yeah and
they were so
uh
that made me kind of like to myself and
that kind of made me afraid of people
all of my circumstances were but if I
could have done things differently I
would have brought things to the
authority probably to help my situation
to stop things before they got any worse
like they did yeah did you feel like
your drug addiction is something you
maybe inherited from your
yes I definitely feel like this drug
addiction runs in my family because it
came past from my grandma to my mom to
me yeah it's interesting that too your
sisters are are not
involved in drugs and two of them are
yeah that's very interesting to think
about that a lot
do you feel like life is unfair
sometimes yes
it's been your worst experience
since you've been living on the streets
my worst experience in sleeping on the
streets is when my mom
my mom hadn't told me that my sister
Alexandra she died because she passed
away from an overdose of Fentanyl
sorry
how long ago was that
was last year in October
you still have hope of maybe
getting off the drugs or getting away
from that
like if thank you
sometimes I have hope like if somebody
brings it to my mind like hey have you
ever thought of quitting like that's the
only time I ever think about quitting
but besides that there is no hope I I
never really do think about quitting
the thought that you might stay on the
streets or OD
is such a
such a real
this is such a serious chance of that
happening now
so many people are dying of fentanyl
it's got to scare you
that's pretty scary and it's unfortunate
and to know that oh my sister is a
victim of that and to kind of think
about the fact that I'm basically doing
and supporting the drug that took her
life is like it makes me feel like a
horrible person like I can't even look
in the mirror
foreign
thing you've learned
in your life
most important thing I've learned in my
life
is to be happy
like
never
let a hard knock on the head bring you
down completely
sometimes you need that hard knock on
the head to put a little sense into you
but that doesn't mean that you cannot
stop smiling and being happy and living
for the moment that's the most important
thing I think I've learned
all right Ashton thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
the best of luck out here thank you so
much thank you very much thank you